Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
A lot of you have been asking me
about this
Marvel reboot news
going around the past week.
There have been a lot of rumors
in my own personal opinion
that Kevin Feige would do a soft reboot
with The Avengers Secret Wars.
But now we actually have some information
straight from the horse's mouth, like
Kevin Feige himself
talking about rebooting the MCU.
So we'll explain what's going on,
what that's going to look like.
It won't be quite the same thing
that James Gunn
is doing in the DC Universe,
but it seems like
it won't be quite as hard of a reboot
as James Gunn is doing.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're doing.
The giveaway for Loki Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know how you want them
to change the MCU with this reboot.
Like what about it?
Do you want them to change?
most of us assume that at some point
the MCU would go on for so long,
it would create so many headaches.
Behind the scenes have become so top heavy
for Marvel and for new viewers.
There just be so many movies,
so much backstory
and lore that the MCU would feel kind
of like one piece for example,
one piece has more than 25 years,
way over 1000 chapters.
Now over 1000
episodes, and many, many movies in there.
It becomes so daunting for new viewers,
like, where do I actually start?
How do I figure this out?
that it almost starts
to feel like homework,
which turns off a lot of new viewers
it would just make more sense
for Kevin Feige
to start fresh with a soft reboot.
Currently, Spider-Man
is probably the best record holder
for reboots of the character.
Tobey Maguire was the main Spider-Man
as recently as 2007 in Spider-Man three,
then Andrew Garfield as soon as amazing,
Spider-Man two in 2014.
Now it's Tom Holland.
Eventually, they will have to reboot
with another version of the character.
To his credit,
Tom Holland does seem like he's
going to stick around
for like the next two Spider-Man four,
Spider-Man five,
or Spider-Man six, which is like almost
another ten years of Spider-Man.
but if you were a little kid
when Iron Man one came out in theaters,
you followed all the MCU movies
up to this point
and you graduated from college now
and you have a real job.
Maybe some of you also
have your own children now.
And now you started taking them to Marvel
movies like, I started watching them
when I was a little kid.
Now I'm taking my little kid
to these movies.
all of you have some experience
with some kind of reboot.
It's nothing new.
Like not a brand new concept,
but more like par for the course.
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
Patrick Stewart's Professor X,
the classic X-Men coming back in Deadpool
three and Secret Wars are exceptions
to that rule, not the standard.
normally people get recast
way more frequently.
The whole phenomenon
of the multiverse movies
where old actors come back
like Spider-Man,
No Way Home and the Flash movie,
for instance, with Michael Keaton's Batman
coming back in Mass in all these different
franchises, is a relatively new thing
the actual quote
where Kevin Feige is talking about
rebooting
the MCU comes from an interviewer
that interviewed him during the ten year
anniversary for Marvel.
So this is Kevin Feige
planning on doing a reboot
actually quite a while ago,
like before Avengers Endgame came out.
this secret wars will serve as a soft
reboot where they can prune everything
that's not working and just keep
what is working or bring back people
you thought were gone forever.
That's basically saying that he's going
to recast some of the main characters,
not just the X-Men, the Fantastic Four.
We knew that that was going to happen
because they're doing
new versions of those movies that they
just announced, the brand new X-Men movie.
They're going to be releasing
the new Fantastic Four movie in 2025.
But also recasting
some of the major characters
that they killed off in like Avengers
Endgame or people who died in real life.
And you thought that their characters
were gone forever.
Then recently,
when Kevin Feige was doing an interview
for the Marvel's movie,
he also said the great thing about Marvel
truly, is how many wonderful, interesting
characters we have in the comics.
They've been at it for 85 years.
Even after 32 movies,
it feels like we barely scratched
the surface they're way,
way over a thousand characters.
For example, Sony,
because they own the rights to Spider-Man,
basically have over 900 characters
just as part of the Spider-Man, right?
So it's just one corner
of the Marvel Universe.
that quote is also Kevin Feige
teasing a bunch of story concepts,
four types of movies that they haven't
really done a lot with before.
I'll get into that in a second
because a lot of that stuff gets into
what they're doing in Marvel Phase
seven and beyond After Secret Wars.
but I like the notion
that Kevin Feige is going to act
kind of like he who remains on Loki,
the Marvel powers that be that
are making all these movies,
are acting like the real TVA,
pruning, everything that they feel like
has not worked that they've done
in the Marvel Universe already.
Like some of the Marvel TV series
that just haven't worked out
some of the Marvel movies
that they felt like
haven't worked out things
about the characters, backstories
that just don't make sense
now with all the new stuff
they're introducing.
in recasting some of their major,
major characters that they can't use
right now because they sunsetted, quote
unquote, the characters
with Avengers Endgame
or the actors passed away in real life.
so here's when we get to that MCU reboot.
Kevin Feige
is using Secret Wars
to give all of the legacy Marvel,
Fox actors their own version of Avengers
Endgame
that they never really got the chance
to have when Fox
was still making the Marvel movies,
But also throwing in Tobey Maguire.
Spider-Man. Andrew Garfield. Spider-Man.
Who are still Sony characters
because he always wanted to have
big Avengers movies with, for instance,
Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man.
That was what the whole deleted scenes
in the first Iron Man Post-Credits
scene was about like he was trying to say
that the X-Men and Spider-Man
characters all existed in the same Earth
as The Avengers
as if gamma accidents, radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't enough,
I have to deal with a spoiled brat.
Doesn't play well with others,
and wants to keep all his toys to himself.
Who the hell are you?
Nick Fury, Too bad the lawyers got in
the way of that actually happening.
but they got in this whole notion
of bringing back the legacy characters,
giving them their own Avengers
type of movie Spider-Man.
No Way Home is a really good example
of a test run of them bringing back
legacy actors like they brought them back
just to see how the audience
would respond to that.
Now we know in retrospect,
everybody loved it.
They'll bring them back in a bigger way.
During Avengers Secret Wars.
Deadpool
three is going to be like the Spider-Man
No Way Home for the classic X-Men actors.
Also kind of a test run to see how
everyone responds to them coming back in.
If it does go well, it seems like it will.
You'll see more of them come back
during secret wars.
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
was always going to come back for secret
wars, though, and he actually called
this giant crossover of all the characters
really early on when they were making
the second Wolverine movie.
I literally asked the same question
the other day to Tom, who's
from Marvel,
who works with all the other studios.
He works with Sony and Fox.
That's his job in the eyes. I said, Man,
can this happen?
And he goes, Look, it's
not going to be easy
because you're working
with different studios
and have their properties that I believe.
Maybe I'm optimistic.
I understand Marvel.
They've got Avengers,
they've got a lot of big things going on,
but at some point I just find it
almost impossible.
There's not a way to bring.
Imagine all the Avengers characters,
you know, Wolverine,
the X-Men characters, Spider-Man,
and somehow get them in together.
the guy that he's talking about inside
Marvel, who is telling him about this,
like, look, we could probably do this,
but it's going to be kind of hard.
There are all these lawyers
that you're going to get in the way.
That was Kevin Feige,
that's why earlier this year
when they released that Deadpool
three teaser trailer,
they thanked Kevin Backer like,
Thank you very much, Kevin Feige.
you, Kevin 5G Love you Kevin 5G.
Thank you, MCU.
speaking of Wolverine specifically,
this is also why, Kevin,
you revealed that Wolverine will not be
in that new rebooted X-Men movie
They just announced
that are feature all new recast actors
playing the main characters.
And Hugh Jackman will still be the main
version of Wolverine through Secret Wars.
There are a lot of people that are calling
this new rebooted version of the MCU
that Kevin Bogey will create the ultimate
MCU universe, like Kevin Brady
doing his version of the Marvel
comic book, Ultimate Universe.
Start Fresh and then also call it
a completely different universe
so that you can leave all these legacy
MCU movies in a separate universe
to all those characters
still technically exist and can come back
if they want to bring them back.
the whole idea with the ultimate universe
is that the Marvel comic book
people felt like there was so much comic
book continuity to keep track of.
It was turning off a lot of potential
new readers, like it'd gone for one piece.
Basically.
so the created the ultimate universe
is like a completely separate
universe, giving all the characters
brave new backstory
starting from issue number one
so that like New viewers could walk
in on day one and read any of the comics
without understanding who the characters
were, Kevin Feige.
The Marvel powers of the B
are just getting worried
that the same thing is starting to happen
with the Marvel movies.
Pretty much everybody in any cinematic
universe usually just does
a complete reboot every 20 years or so,
sometimes more frequently than that.
If you're a Spider-Man for example, Warner
Brothers is now rebooting Harry Potter.
It hasn't been that long
since the original Harry Potter movies.
Pretty much everything gets rebooted
in some fashion at some point.
It's just that it's the first time
for it to happen to the MCU because
2008 with Iron Man
one doesn't feel like that long ago
but by the time we get past secret wars,
it will have been about 20 years
in right now very apropos.
It's also happening to DC movies.
James Gunn is rebooting all those.
The major difference, though,
between James Gunn's DC movie reboot
and the MCU reboot is the MCU
reboot is more of a soft reboot.
James Gunn is recasting like almost 98%
of all those characters
Kevin Feige is only going to be recasting
maybe like 20 or 25% of the characters,
maybe even less than that.
Remember the quote that the interview got
from him about Bring Back day characters?
Characters
you never thought that you'd see again,
that means new versions of Iron Man,
Black Panther, the X-Men, Fantastic Four,
some of those we already knew about,
but not many people had actually thought
about them.
Recasting Iron Man, for example,
one of the other major goals of this soft
reboot after Secret Wars is saying that
in the new backstory of this rebooted MCU,
whatever you want to call ultimate MCU,
will be that all these different types
of characters from the comics
all existed in the same universe,
on the same earth this whole time
So this new version of the MCU will feel
more like the traditional 616 comic book
universe, where everybody's always existed
in the same universe.
They'll probably use this reboot
to make the MCU the true 616 universe.
Look,
it will look truly like the comic book
616 Universe end, they'll just say that
Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man,
the Fantastic Four,
all the other legacy actors still exist.
They're just from other universes.
So like, the original
MCU will just exist in another universe
what do you want them to do
with the new version of Iron Man?
Since Robert Downey Jr is Iron
Man is so iconic
and basically the foundation of the MCU,
like they wouldn't have a studio now today
if it weren't for Iron Man one.
Who do you want to play that character?
we're probably not going to see that new
version of Iron Man for a good long while.
Like Curly Secret Wars
is supposed to release in 2027.
that might get delayed again
and they might
turn it into two different movies.
So it's totally possible
we don't see the new version of Iron Man
until like 2029 or a little bit later.
in that would be a little over 20 years
since Iron Man one debuted
which sounds pretty reasonable.
I just talked to Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield.
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video, Empires 14.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details
my Loki Season 2 Episode 3 Video
We'll post later this week.
After they release it,
click here to learn about the Loki Season
2 Council of Kings deleted scenes
in a bunch of deleted scenes
with the King Multiverse war that didn't
make it into season 2 and click here
for all my Loki Season 2 episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!